es sieht nicht nur aus wie in einem
krieg es ist einer der findet weitgehend
im verborgenen statt im dickicht des
amazonas-regenwaldes diese bilder
erstmals exklusiv im deutschen fernsehen
zu sehen zeigen einen aktuellen
kampfeinsatz der brasilianischen
waldbehörde ibama ein einsatz der den
beamten später noch zum verhängnis
werden sollte zu jagen illegale
goldschürfer und holzfäller die weit in
das schutzgebiet indigener völker
vorgedrungen sind
in zeiten von corona sind die
eindringlinge noch gefährlicher für die
indigenen sie zerstören nicht nur ihren
lebensraum sie bringen auch das virus
das team entdeckt eine riesige goldmine
zerstörter wald verseuchter boden
die täter flüchten was sie hinterlassen
zeigt wie professionell hier geschürft
wurde das hier ist eine illegale
landebahn
es ist klar wer eine landebahn eröffnet
der hat grosses wirtschaftliches
vermögen
außerdem haben wir hier hinten 10.000
liter benzin
das zeigt wie gut diese goldgräber
städte funktioniert und gold aus dem
land der indigenen cloud ihre waffen
haben die schiffer zurückgelassen
vor der staatsmacht flüchten sie meist
doch für die indigenen deren land sie
hier verwüsten sind sie eine tödliche
gefahr
überall in brasilien versuchen die
indigenen völker verzweifelt sich
abzuschotten und errichten etwas das
eigentlich nicht teil ihrer kultur ist
zäune bauen sie beim stamm der mur am
amazonas gerade indigene völker leiden
immer wieder unter eingeschleppten
infektionskrankheiten die immunsystem
nicht kennt er ist die holzfäller jetzt
corona sie haben angst
sie dringen in unser gebet ein und
bauten unsere reichtümer aus die
regierung spielt mit auch sie will
unsere reichtümer ausbeuten und mit dem
virus wird alles noch schwieriger die
indigenen völker brasiliens fühlen sich
im stich gelassen von einer regierung
einen präsidenten der ihre kultur nicht
respektiert der stamm der karibuni wurde
schon einmal durch eine eingeschleppte
krankheit fast ausgerottet und schon bei
unserem letzten besuch vor einem jahr
führten sie einen blutigen abwehrkampf
gegen die holzfäller
jetzt ruft der häuptling um hilfe wir
könnten von zwei tragödien getroffen
werden die erste die ansteckung mit dem
corona virus und die zweite ein massaker
sie haben uns schon damit gedroht dass
sie uns umbringen werden wegen unseres
landes wir sind vorsichtig und wir haben
angst
für den trupp der waldbehörde obama ist
klar hinter dem raubbau am regenwald
stecken gut organisierte finanzkräftige
hintermänner
es handelt sich um verbrecher die von
organisierten banden finanziert werden
müssen wenn sie das geld haben um so
eine maschine zu kaufen und sie hier auf
das land der indigenen zu bringen sie
zerstören nicht nur das umwelt erbe
brasiliens sondern sie schaden unserem
land auch wirtschaftlich denn das gold
das sie hier abbauen wird illegal und
heimlich weiter verkauft sie machen
kurzen prozess und zünden die ausrüstung
im wert von mehreren hunderttausend euro
an
normalerweise beschlag nahmen sie die
geräte doch ein transport ist zu
schwierig und sie wollen auf nummer
sicher gehen dass sie nicht wieder in
falsche hände geraten doch solch ein
etappensieg kann nichts daran ändern
dass auch die staatlichen umweltschützer
der ibama zusehends auf verlorenem
posten kämpfen
präsident zuma hat im wahlkampf der
mächtigen holz agrar und bergbau lobby
versprochen den regenwald für eine
wirtschaftliche ausbeutung zu öffnen
seit er an der macht ist wurden die
mittel für den umweltschutz drastisch
gekürzt auch die waldbehörde wurde stark
geschwächt budgets und personal
zusammengestrichen
die korona krise scheint die lage noch
zu verschärfen
der prozess der invasion der indigenen
ländereien willich goldgräber und
holzfäller hat zugenommen
vielleicht weil man erwartete dass den
kontrollbehörden nicht das
durchhaltevermögen haben während sich
das corona virus weiter ausbreitet wohl
zur nahrungs worte seine politik und das
virus eine tödliche kombination für den
regenwald und die indigenen völker
beklagen umweltschützer
wenn es jetzt eine günstige gelegenheit
gibt weil die welt und brasilien weniger
hinschauen dann werden die landbesitzer
diese nutzen und das ist bereits
sichtbar
die leute die das land besetzt halten
sagen wir sind hier weil der präsident
sagt dass er das erlaubt offizielle
stellen bestätigen die befürchtungen die
staatliche weltraumbehörde die den wald
per satellit überwacht verzeichnet einen
starken anstieg der abholzung
wir sind noch nicht einmal in der
schlimmsten phase der abholzung die
kritische phase beginnt erst jetzt im
mai im mai juni und juli dürften sich
diese zahl noch weiter erhöhen
was wir also erwarten ist eine
steigerung im vergleich zum vorjahr auch
die männer der ibama entdecken auf ihrem
flug immer wieder neue stellen und dann
sogar ein professionelles sägewerk
mitten im regenwald jahrhundertealte
bäume streng geschützt wurden hier
verarbeitet das ist die illegale
abholzung auf indigenen gebiet das hier
ist ein paradox baum der gefällt wurde
der rest liegt hier schauen wie groß der
baum war auch hier vernichten die
ba-mitarbeiter die ausrüstung und genau
dieses gründliche vorgehen wird ihnen
wenig später zum verhängnis
wenige tage nach bekanntwerden der
operation werden die verantwortlichen
entlassen
angeblich so schreiben zeitungen soll
sich präsident ball szenario über die
beharrlichkeit der waldschützer geärgert
haben
inzwischen ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft ob die männer zu
unrecht entlassen wurden um der
mächtigen holz lobby einen gefallen zu
tun
das wäre ein skandal
doch auch wenn sich der verdacht nicht
bestätigt es steht so schlecht wie lange
nicht mehr um den regenwald und die
indigenen völker die korona pandemie ist
eine zusätzliche gefahr und versperrt
zugleich den blick auf das sterben im
wald dabei hat die eigentliche saison
der holzfäller und brandstifter noch gar
nicht richtig angefangen